hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again and
just as I predicted I had a feeling we
were gonna have a trailer this Tuesday
and look at that my suspicions were true
we're gonna be looking at the trailer
that was also part of that teaser that
we got last week but this is the trailer
for the newest hero Holda we'll get into
a little bit of why the name is hold on
and stuff like that in the video but as
always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the year
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
horror and never miss out on an update
that meets this subscribe to the channel
and with that let's get started with
this trailer breakdown so the new hero
Holda has a trailer released remember
this season and next season all the
characters are going to be having both
genders so in season 9 we had Vorta girl
but the actual name was black prior and
season 10 we had Sakura but the actual
name was hito Peary and this one it
seems like the female name is gonna be
holed up but the male name is uncertain
and also the actual name is uncertain
but judging from the description of the
video its other going to be Ragnarok or
which I believe is correct or it's going
to be German gundarr I totally ruined
that name I'm so sorry she also has some
piercings and face paint for some
variation so there's gonna be a lot of
customization there depending on what
rank you're gonna be at I'm assuming as
the higher you go up you'll still be
getting piercings and face paints and
stuff I'm wondering if the male version
will also have some sort of piercings as
well and if the male version doesn't
have piercings and it's a female
exclusive thing I'm assuming that the
male will have different beard styles
and then also both characters will
probably have some different hair styles
maybe a ponytail kind of like how shaman
has for her one haircut or the male is
just gonna have this long drape of hair
kind of like Jay Jay except you can't
really see it because his hat is
covering it going off the trailer we
have this cinematic shot from the teaser
and to confirm why the character has no
beard or build in that teaser it was
because it wasn't a huge [ __ ] and it
was because that was a female
everyone kind of thought that it was
either going to be a very kind of skinny
looking male or if that was a female so
if anybody guessed that that was a
female in the teaser you're correct
there's a lots of red lightning going
everywhere in giant serpent there's a
giant serpent cloud that comes out of
nowhere which is super crazy
there's the waves crashing into the
rocks a very dark atmosphere very spooky
is what really fits into that year of
the Harbinger feel we can also get a
better look at the size of this hammer
while also in looking at a variation of
what the hair
gonna look like and if we remember back
from the teaser black prior also had one
that was green and gold but his default
one is not that it's actually more of a
gray or black tone so that could also be
that could be a higher tier version of
the weapon or a lower tier version of
the weapon in the teasers that we've
known for Four Seasons but this one who
knows what this one's gonna be I feel
like that's gonna be a lower tier
version just because I can see a lot of
rust in that weapon somewhat yeah but
she holds it above her head with one
hand and like I said it's still very
unclear just even looking at the size of
this hammer whether it's going to be a
one-handed or two-handed weapon I'm
really still thinking it's going to be a
combination of the two because that
staff that she's holding it or the shaft
that she has is a very long one it
doesn't seem like it's going to be
fitting for any one-handed type of con
combat unless it's gonna be like heat so
kiri where she does the zone attack with
one hand by the way let me know what you
guys think about this girl in the
comments below I'm gonna be trying to do
a little bit of a lore video before this
character releases trying a little
probably no search up a little bit I'm
very excited to see what's happening
with her
I completely forgot that they had a
website linked to all this stuff so I'm
gonna be reading that really quickly it
says for honor year 3 season 3 titled
Hulda is coming on August 1st 2019 and
this brings with it the Jormungand are a
new feral viking hero playable in both
the female version named Hoba and the
male version named great are versions
the german Gandhara are viking section 2
sectarians devoted to the mythical Great
Serpent
after which they are renamed under with
the mighty Warhammer they called the
week before the arrival of Ragnarok as
only the strongest may fight in the
battle to come
the year 3 pass holders will have
immediate access to Roman Gondar when
season 3 launches on August 1st all
other players will be able to purchase
the new hero on August 8th for 15,000
in-game steel in addition to the new
hero season 3 brings a new battlefield
to the fold the Viking fortress of store
stronghold which will be added into the
breach mode map rotation and will be
free for all players this is huge
incredible news because we haven't had a
breach mode map since their launch a
breach so that's super exciting on top
of that additionally no bushi shinobi
and Orochi will be seating balance
updates to make them more competitive so
if I had to guess I'm assuming Nobu she
might be getting slightly a bit of a
nerf she's very powerful in brawls and a
lot of other game modes and I'm assuming
if that might count as the rework is
but if I had to bet shinobi will most
likely beginning a rework in season 11
and Orochi might also receive another
one or a big balance change but that is
just my opinion if that's gonna be those
three characters on top of more reworks
than I'll be even happier with that but
either way I'm still kind of satisfied
with Nobu she a shinobi and Orochi both
receiving updates to make them more
competitive within game and also just in
case strowman Gondar is also the 25th
hero to enter the 4 on our roster so we
have loads of characters to play around
with now yeah let me know what you guys
think of all Holda in the comments below
also let me know what you guys think
about the Noguchi Orochi and the shinobi
rework stuff if that happens to be
reworked or if that's just balance
changes I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say that that is the current rework
someone or one of those is probably most
likely gonna be balance changes I'm
assuming Orochi but I think no bushi and
shinobi are most likely going to be
getting some type of rework for season
11 yeah but let me know in the comments
below do you guys think elective II if
you do enjoy subscribe for a new a cover
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe the
channel
with that guys look today if you're
doing Joe and that guys take care have a
great yesterday and peace out I'll see
you guys in a couple days for the reveal
stream
[Music]